welcome to this video aqua be one or
something like that so what do we get
trying the Queens gambit accepted okay
I'm going actually accidentally it is
six ok oh I don't really know is this
hmm
yeah anyway I sort of stumbled to this
anyway can you go to 5 or how is this
didn't really look like it so castles
yeah 95 Bishop g4 yeah okay it's not
very exciting if you go screen g4 he
doesn't so interesting for Queen sorry
for up to three yeah those positions are
really something that i don't like a lot
or well i don't like them at all it's
just that i'm sort of the said stumbled
stumbled into this but here i feel i'm
ok yeah when i get the night to g6
hmm that should be ok I think Bishop 1c
success is is active and something like
Queen age for might be might be in to
get rid of the Queen's b5 could be a
weakness in some situations yeah I think
it should be somewhat okies up should be
ok this position
so I think Queen age for all right
there's no grid square anyway for the
Queen and this is not so bad the night
on h4 is some also putting pressure I
should remove that pressure on the g2
pond so tries to trade with fishermen
fires but I'm pretty quick on the D file
g2 hangs so if he goes route d3 I can
take the three TG tool maybe you can
drum up some kind of compensation they
have it okay here interesting I can take
d1 tech g2 just for work against to
minors there's something better
check not sure really I wonder if I have
something better even some says some
trickery if I take on gtalk t8 no rook
c8 look T 893 hmm it's not clear that's
not clear at all you can also go back to
g64 night against bishop which isn't bad
either tough to say let's do it Oh Beth
not overlooking some some stupid traps
trap of the fees but it didn't happen ok
so if i go here Knight c3 be 583 oopsie
5 just about works maybe like g5 and
Roxy five or something yeah not sure
right is this ok here
and it's not how I envisioned it to be
but so it's not bad for black I think
but it's not what I thought would happen
AKA five no it's not doing that mm f
five chicks chicks equals f five maybe
jello yeah I goes f5 now himself hmm
takes Knight takes king of seven
chickens if or I hope I'm not stumbling
into some you 595 king of some hmm I
know if I've as good a lot too tricky
the same come on let's do it check I
think it was a good decision he five is
a protected person which isn't it's not
going to like quickly promote anything
but he has to worry about the pawn mmm
download time this is this is worrisome
v5 maybe it's going back there ok I have
Roxy form if it takes on age 5 and Roxy
to the other group gets active now quite
often looking pawns better against than
two minor pieces time morning I
originally thought that would be such a
position but the way it panned out
didn't really support this this is a DM
r this evaluation have to go to h4
really should have done that should have
done that immediately check okay let's
grab this first before I do anything
else so look here oh i blundered that
really blundered that porn not good I
wanted to go rookie to which is of
course entirely wrong check and then be
too maybe
93 is he is blocking the same
unbelievable don't check yeah check
that's just a draw-game drum Gerry Nash
would win this of course somewhere
around here i plundered all the porns
wow this was still ok i really i really
did not did not register that i'm
dropping a 6 this is just as bad just
this probably sometimes something like
this through get through pawns ready and
it's it's it it gets it since quick now
ever take between mm-hmm was there there
was a difficult decision that capture
lungi to hear ya maybe just 96 I mean
this is this is something that also
comes into consideration really jigs f
shakes and it's slightly weak a bishop
is a bit better but can you do something
there yeah this is probably giving
better winning chances then then the
endgame that I chose check that's Nyjah
to business I was really thinking my
book would be more active but its own it
didn't pan out check check check
yeah here's somehow he must have made
some some inaccurate moves as I really
got into it got somewhere which probably
shouldn't happen very difficult look and
pawn against two minuses always a
difficult issue okay well thanks for
watching